e
Mr chair I move approval of the minutes
as written and presented okay second
second okay uh any
discussion none okay all in favor
approving minutes I anybody opposed no
thank
you okay um first item of the agenda uh
Charlie and I did go to the the
executive council
meeting we were we were 66 on the on the
Hit
Parade so I I spent a lot of time in the
Carter catching up a lot of people so it
was kind of a fun day for me but um
turns
out they really we were on the agenda we
should really technically have been on
consent calendar I guess uh but they had
no questions about the Spectrum proposal
they just wanted to ask Charlie about
how's how's March Madness going
and and uh you know how's Powerball
going I mean basically that's what it
amounted to but no problem getting this
through the executive Council so what
what Charlie and I going to do is
sometime the week this week or maybe
next is but make contact with who the
actual consultant is and hopefully we
can have him either physically here or
um or do another Zoom with the
consultant that we're going to be
working with so that'll be next meeting
we'll talk about that the date of that
next you know later in the meeting so
but that's that's the so no Pro
everything's approved contract signed
everything contract signed right yeah
yeah I signed it yeah okay you sign it
before you submitted
okay I'm not sure the process so um but
anyway so that that all went fine
uh one of the things that Charlie
forward the second General item third
General item is the
survey I Charlie did send us all the um
results of the survey was pretty thick
honest okay to be honest with you I
didn't I was busy doing some other
summaries of some of the other data we
had picked up um I didn't really go
through detail
myself um but from what I can see it's a
lot of data but really there's really no
there's really no conclusion I guess
maybe Charlie you can just help us out a
little bit with that yeah I mean I think
the report speaks for itself and
certainly you folks can read the
findings and results I think one of the
takeaways was that the Charities weren't
particularly happy with rent but since
we you know the legislature appears to
be addressing that that's not an issue
at least won't be an issue soon um
but if we want to do another study on
it's 147 Pages 22 pages of findings and
then the the remainder is the sort of
the raw data and the questions answered
and the some of the questions were
open-ended in terms of a response was
not a click button it was a please fill
in the blank here and so all those
responses are in the data it's 147 pages
I pray no one hit print um and if you
did I apologize and I can send you some
paper and some ink um but if you want to
read it over obviously it wasn't sent
out till last week so if you want to
read it over and we can discuss to the
next meeting that would make more sense
or if you want to have the researcher
come in and testify about it and their
findings or recommendations we can do
that too it's open to the
membership well did
it
yeah yeah I think um that makes sense to
uh hold this over until the next meeting
and have chance to look at it I did uh
read through
it the first part rapidly um but uh yeah
there a few thing I think there were a
few things in there that
mer um at least attention yeah
yeah represent yeah I thought that you
know the was great I kind of glance
through the whole thing uh nothing that
I did not expect being a charity you if
you want that they're very very similar
all the way through but I think that one
of the things it gives us is assumptions
versus reality and at least the two are
seem to be coming together but it's it's
great to be able to uh to have survey to
get as many Charities as did respond so
that I think it was about 75% something
like that here yeah I mean fundamentally
with any research study when n equals
more than 400 it's a valid survey it's
accur within a couple 3% so this wasn't
a question of my fear is you know two or
three is come in here and they're
handpicked per I'm not saying that they
are but you you never wonder you wonder
and this would being hundreds and
hundreds and hundreds this is all of the
Charities almost so statistically
valid okay that's really good any other
comments on
this so regarding the rent the the rent
which seemed you said was a top uh the
Senate we already voted on it um I I
FastTrack it in the Senate um so it's
been voted out of committee it's been
voted on the senate floor and I've asked
to be fast tracked to the governor's
office because as a 60-day delay in
implementation my goal was to have it
start July 1 and get it to the
governor's office get it signed so the
60-day starts right away starts within
in the 60 days so on a calendar cycle so
I I'm not sure where it is in the fast
track um like I said I we we already
voted on it um two weeks
ago I look it up um but I FasTrack that
of the Senate I got the Senate President
to sign it and send it over to the uh
back to the speaker because it was a
house bill and then the speaker's office
has to Fast Track it I've asked for it I
don't know exactly where it is in the
process yet so is it I'll say it again
is it is it effective the effective date
ju no the effective date is 60 days
after passage so if I can get it to the
governor by May 1 and he signs it on May
1st then 60 days later is July 1 right
and we're in good shape so that's what
I'm trying to make happen is get it so
that it gets to him so he can have it
before May 1 and be able to sign off on
it so the 60-day cycle will start I'm
trying to get to do it on the beginning
of a month rather than the middle of the
cycle okay anything else on this no
okay uh next item um I'd ask for recent
data uh these two documents one is one
is February 2 of
23 and the other one is February of
24 then what I did what I did and it's
also in front of
you is I summarized it into one one
sheet paper if you want to
look
okay um and then I at the on the bottom
of this
sheet I uh I compare it to the Baseline
I'm considering the Baseline for our
discussions count year
22 so if you if you can look at this
sheet okay it uh on we have the 23 data
and then we have the 24 data and was
broken down as far as it included poker
poker tournaments so poker tournaments
games of chance historic racing and then
total and then
allocations to facilities charities in
the
state and you could and then with the
same same columns for February 24 so
we're comparing February to February
unfortunately we're comparing a February
to a leap year February so there was one
more day in 24
but you can see that the significant
jump that's occurred in the revenues uh
between one year and the
next uh and you know total total revenue
including facilities charities in the
state what one uh
increased seven almost 8
million uh over that
period
obviously the the the big jump was in uh
actually the big jump was
facilities were up four 5.5
million or
84.7% the Charities were up $1.1 million
or
58.8% and the state was up
$1.67 million or up
83.3% and that's the effect of historic
racing bullet kicking in well not
falling it's only in nine or 10
facilities right now not every facility
has has it in
place um and again this is this is the
this is the issue that we're going to be
addressing through the consultant of
what are the splits are are good or not
uh but everybody gained facilities
gained Charities gained State
gained uh the state was really getting
minimal from the games of chance they're
getting a lot more out of
the from uh historic racing which is
probably okay from the cost of
oversight uh but again the only number
we're going to be checking out I mean
the big number we're going to be
checking out is is the allocation of
between facilities and the Charities if
you
will so when you go down to the bottom
of
this um I took if you remember the Green
Sheet we handed out
this this was a while ago and I compared
calendar year
22 to fiscal year 23 then uh and then
uh from July 22nd to June 23rd and then
and then calendar year 23 January to
December
23 so what I did is I took as the base
year that first calendar the calendar
year J you know
22 so
and we can see given from the base
here of uh where the
split Revenue split was 60.5% of
facilities 27.9% of Charities and
11.6% to to the
state and then I annualized the February
number of 23 so I took the numbers
divided by 28 time 365
probably sees an alley in here somewhere
for some facilities just to give us a
sense so that showed if we annualize
February as to what what 24 is going to
look like you know we're we're from the
baseline from the base here of 22 we're
up
78.1% total revenues and if we if I took
February and annualized
it it really increases by uh from the
base year $ 53
million so or
208% so everything's
growing
okay uh and again for the annualized
number you you could see that the
facilities went up 60 60.5 base share
went to
66.5% then
68.5 Charities went from
27.9%
19.4% and 17. 2% in the state went
percentage wise went up uh from from
11.6% to 14.1% to
14.3% so again it's just informational
for us just see things are growing we
could see that uh from the numbers of
more more the reason for us to make sure
the oversight's correct and that the
allocations are are correct uh because
where we we got the tiger by the tail
here so yes Senator hey Charlie can I
get four more data points on 23 and 24
February sheet can I get on the on the
games of chance I'm interested in the
number of facilities that were active at
that same so we're comparing Apples to
Apples we know how many facilities if we
had more facilities it's going to change
the the metric what we're looking at and
on the HHR remue the number of
machines because I again I well we're
looking at percentage of gross overall
handle I'm guessing is what we're
looking at here we also have to
recognize that like when you do your 22
23 24 they went from 20 M Charities went
from $20 million $39 million a your
doubling of Revenue um going to
Charities even though the percentages
might have adjusted the Charities also
uh did did significantly well as so just
just making sure we're talking about the
percentages while we're talking about
gross handle number of facilities number
of machines as well as um you know
recognizing that we're not talking about
a percentage of of Revenue
year-over-year we're talking about the
percent the percentage of the gross
handle that's all I'd actually suggest
we add a couple more metrics to like
sort of the average per machine average
per facility right well that's I fig
that out once I know what those other
numbers are yeah yeah yeah
no but just so we understand because we
know that um we know that uh back in 22
we didn't have very many operators that
were running HHR at all right and so
trying to correlate 22 to 24 when we
have 1800 machines compared to we might
have had a few hundred machines in 22
yeah that's important to understand what
that metric looks like and we're going
to have another large facility come
online in less than a year um which will
increase the number um by 60% right so
just again just trying to make sure
we're looking we all have the same
picture and again how how the growth of
the industry is happen is important us
understand how the revenue growth is
also happening so
so with that statement though Charlie um
home for have been approve approved yet
right no additional facilities have been
approved have
they no additional facilities have been
approved correct but some are in the
process of building new facilities
within their movable jurisdiction so
that one one equals one just one's going
from X to so you mean the facility 12x
talking about the facility Nation yes
yeah okay that's moving to a new
building so we have the issue of again I
think when we started this we started
this last year in 23 there was seven
seven rooms that had HHR now I think
we're up to 10 there still four more
that potentially could get HHR that are
under current law correct yeah correct
so there's still room in there and then
there's the ones that are in the
pipeline and the ones that are in the
pipeline based on 472 and some of the
other pills yes may be approved which
may be approved certainly you know the I
keep getting calls I'm like it's still
the L still exists it's it it is in law
now whether it's new law is a different
question
okay all right um oh
yes just a question are are is our
consultant going to help us look ahead
and think about where this these HHR
revenues might be headed um you know
it's all guesstimation I guess but uh
but uh we're we're in a you know
sharp uh slope going up um at some point
it's going to level off and maybe even
competition from around will uh uh even
change the trend from from the plateau
that's reached to start with so are we
going to be looking at the yeah I think
I think we got to we got to discuss one
of the ways one of the things we got to
look at is we we you you were in the
middle of all this when we did the uh
regular Casino
bills what's the saturation point in
terms of the number of
machines and I think we'd be asking the
consultant to work to give us a sense
given the population here and the and
the market maybe in Mass you know
Northern mass and the Western
Maine a little bit of Vermont but you
know what is the saturation Point uh and
do we want to put a limit on the number
of machines total you know now you could
say let's we could have the marketplace
to that too eventually they're G you
know someone's going to say well it's
not worth it because we have so many of
these machines
around right now it seems like the
dollar per machine has been pretty
good um in terms of exceeding our
original thoughts as to what they they
would produce but El I think we need to
have some guidance as
to as we further discuss and I mean I
know the legislature is putting the
seveny year moratorium is that correct
Senator that's the bill that's currently
in front of ways and means in the house
side Senate passed a seven-year
moratorium with the incremental growth
of the industry for the people that are
already in the pipeline John do you have
anything to add there it's it's over
your place the the moratorium the
seven-year addition is that have you
guys taken that up or
okay we had a public hearing on it but
we haven't uh done anything further yeah
I will say there was interest and as
soon as the house finishes it expedite
that bill as well because of the fact
that we're looking at a j June 30th date
on a moratorium I most likely we'll take
those that and and other bills up a week
from tomorrow most like it's not in the
calendar yet but that's the thought
right now
so I have another question yeah sure
it's sort of the context we're working
in that's my question about where we're
headed to in revenue is prob these games
that we have in front of us um another
activity that may be outside our
frame but um it's certainly happening
and that is sports
betting and there's uh that that like
historic horse racing seems to be
taking off Charlie you can tell me that
that's not so but that's my impression
anyway so you you think there's a link
between sports betting and store horse
racing the there's a drop off with the
growth of store horse racing I certain
no not necessarily both are grow yeah
both are grow yeah so sports betting is
still growing the number of users is
still growing F folks who actually use
and bet on Sports is increasing in the
state what we did lose is we lost a
small but very enthusiastic number of
VIPs at retail uh we had a few that
would average you know 10 20
$330,000 a weekend in sports betting um
it's just what they like to do they're
quite wealthy just what they like to do
um and so those folks are going in
Boston now because it's closer to home
and we're also lost a smaller number but
still significant number of folks who
would drive up here to use their phone
to bet you know the portsman traffic
circle and the mall at Nashville real
popular um for folks from M to drive up
so we've lost those two but by and large
it's been they've both been successful
New Hampshire is the number two
jurisdiction in the country for state
revenue in sports betting out of 38 n
something like that so New York's one
we're two so yeah but and restor will
continue to grow um there are a number
of facilities coming as you know the
we're not to the maximum number yet and
that will I think we'll meet I think
we'll hit Market saturation before we
have the maximum number of facilities
online
um so I I think it would it would be
have let me back up one one of the
aspects of sport bet sports betting is
uh the uh physical location the sports
book you call them um places and I know
the brook is one I don't know what else
uh where where they are but I think it
would be helpful to have that picture at
least beside alongside of what we're
looking at here so that we've got a a
more complete picture of betting that's
going on and casino activity after all
the brook is a casino and within that
casino is sports betting book and um you
know if you go in there it's all seem
it's all in a well they partitions but
it's all in the same
room uh without a doubt and people slide
from this to that sure yeah that's a
10 so just two things so Charlie if I
remember right we're not even at we only
allowed 10 game 10 retail locations and
I think we only have four or five I'm
not sure which four four we've only
reached four so far to the 10 that are
possible um and then as a percentage of
Revenue the retail Market is pretty
insignificant compared to the online
Market it's material not significant
yeah so it's um terms of our handle it's
probably % give or take given them and
so terms of profitability it's much
lower than that um and but it is an
environment I mean if you've been to the
brook you know it's a it's like a a
sports bar you can actually bet on stuff
at it's sort of the mentality similarity
to Manchester as well it's a environment
some folks just like to be in a physical
environment some folks want to do it on
a phone I I just making sure we
understand Revenue pie it's only we're
only at 40% of possible we the bill that
uh that we past 418 um only has 10 10
possible locations so even if we have 20
casinos at the end of this when we're
all done only 10 of them can have sports
recil sports books correct and
fundamentally I think we're going to
have to look and even internally and I
know you and I have spoken on it about
Shifting the the the revenue share model
to make it profitable for facilities to
do it because there it's one of the
limiting factors um say is is there
certain rest of these facilities right
pardon they have sports
oh yeah downside it's also one of the
reasons why only charlot beging
facilities have launched them is because
they have so many of these operations
already in place you know the financial
reporting the anti-money laundering the
the kyc all all the sort of responsible
gambling practices surveillance money
count that there's already so many of
these activities in place that a new
facility would have hard time doing it
because they don't have all obviously
the other side the charitable ging
facilities
to okay
yeah I think one of thing that's
important is when we're looking at the
saturation and uh the monitori is
basically giving those operators a
chance again if you want to kind of see
what their what their base is if you
want a revenue and that we can see that
they're adding amenities if you want to
the um to the gaming rooms and that uh
if you have too many then you go over
and you start cutting down the um
yeah the vibe if you want okay in a in a
particular room if you want that it's
it's it's much nicer if you want or more
enthusiastic for a player to go in
especially new ones if it's a u if it's
the the Parker U the rooms again if you
want or the uh um roulette Etc here if
you've got 15 players around again here
we're betting on the item versus two so
that uh that's where I think the moror
the oratorium is going to kind of help
you can try to find out exactly where it
is one question on the two items that
you that you put out the two
reports the can you tell me the again on
the February
2024 on the orange bottom I see tied to
your comparison of uh
poker report that that you made uh Mr
chairman can you tell me what the green
is up on top that's tournament
tournament
tournament yeah that's tournament that's
tournament this difference between
tournament poker and ra cash
poker so the the cash cash poke help me
correct me if I'm wrong Charlie the the
cash poker is part of the uh uh games of
chance Revenue cash poker gam okay then
this tournament poker okay it's in there
it's not it's not shown as a separate
number any on any other report because
it's buried in with it's part of part of
part of g a chance uh correct me
somebody am I correct thank you so so
this cash poker is part of games chance
revenue and then but po poker tournament
not every not every facility has does
tournaments um is is calculate
separately there
um for a reason because the money sep
treated
separately okay yes uh I just wanted to
go back quickly to director McIntyre's
statement about New Hampshire's numbers
two in sports betting is that per capita
or total um per capita okay per capita
so uh last year we made $38 million uh
in profitability from sports betting
which is essentially quadruple what we
anticipated when I first did the fiscal
note all right so I like being wrong
that way yeah I I'm sure you folks do
right thank
you okay any other comments on this
particular item no okay thank
you uh next one uh again there's a lot
of issues I'm just trying to tick off
here uh license transfer
status now we
did uh on your desk is
also piece of paper here
where it basically indicates the statute
for HHR related to
transfer RSA 284
22b section two reads an application
that is approved by Lottery Commission
and a license that is granted shall not
be permitted to be transferred or
sold and for the under the games of
chance statutes RSA 287d colon 4 Roman 3
reads no license shall be
transferable
so I gu is pretty clear that license
cannot be
transferred but businesses can be
transferred correct that's correct so
business can be
sold but they but the business before
that transaction would probably have to
apply for a license before that that's
correct so so it's want to make sure
everybody aware of that that's why I'm
bringing it up
so we have a situation in conquer as we
all know um there's they were given six
months
to sell
it um sell the business sell the
business they licensed they'd have to
whoever that business is if they wanted
to remain a
casino charal gaming location as it say
uh would have to get it a license
approved
is that
correct yep I think I'm following up on
something down the center of the table
from a couple meetings
ago no this is good um the
um the question that arises is whether
uh there is any limit on the numbers of
licenses that can be held by a
single owner um and um I believe that
right now there is none so right now um
a uh a
company uh that starts out
uh uh early in the game and has a
license can uh look across the border
and uh to the next town and and by um
that company becomes a a subsidiary of
the first company
and um and now that company has two
licenses and so it could go across the
state we have no as far as I know
there's no limitation unless uh our
friend at the end of the table knows
about monopolies uh and some some
limitation there but I don't think so
yeah we don't have any ANC compressed
there's a there's a general
constitutional provision
regarding no
monopolies yeah that's about the only
thing I can think of in terms of the
there's a specific constitutional the
state shall not pass laws which create
monopolies but we know of at least one
owner that has maybe four licenses
that's it's it's five but certainly Li
you know I view the issue as more of a
how much of the marketplace you control
um do you have one giant shopping mall
or do you have five small strip malls so
fundamentally the percentage of the
marketplace is No One controls a
majority of the market yet in terms of
then I I'd like to suggest that this
issue be on our on our list of issues to
to address and uh make sure whether or
not there should be a limit on the uh
Holdings of one company of the overall
number of licenses that are out there or
of so a question with regard to a
followup
of what my colleague said uh it seems at
this point at this point in time we have
no regulation on the number of of
entities you the number of entities you
can have uh and if you look at the uh
television advertising that's that's
appearing it appears that that there's
one entity that has four licenses right
that's what it appears now the the
question the question that arises is is
is
too what's the cost of a
license and if if the cost of a license
is so di Minimus I'd buy
10 what what what prevents anybody from
from doing that and then you you just uh
aggregate the number of Charities that
want something or want want to
participate and and you can put them in
any one of these these
locations it it it it seems to me that's
kind of the base issue that that we're
addressing a what is the cost of a
license and the number of licenses that
will be allocated ated and is there a
restriction on the number of licenses
that one entity uh can own we're talking
about
transferability in in in in legislation
but that transferability I think is
governed by the decision that was made
in the case versus the cant situation
where where that that entity was given
permission to to sell that license or it
appears that way we just heard that's
not the case did I misunderstand
something are they're going to be
allowed to sell the license not the
license the business the business
they're going to sell the business sell
the business but is the license
business they they that it seems to me
that that that business has that
business has one value but that business
with the license has another
value it's the right to apply for storic
horse racing that business has it it's
the valuable thing not the license
itself there's not there's not a
transferable license there isn't a
license really it's just that that
business was operating gam a chance at a
certain time period
when you could as a business supply
versal course raising that's what the
value of the business is but certainly
um I I'm hesitant to speak further on it
true understand but that that's that's
overriding our our our decisionmaking
process here it it it seems me that's
that's that's that's something that's
hanging over this this group because the
decision's going to be made there
there's one one decision that came down
but the second decision what happens
after this this period of time you know
what what ha what has transpired during
that period of time and what effect does
that have going
forward thank you Mr CH
soor yeah no I'm actually f again I I
think the argu the discussion is whether
we limit the consolidation of licenses
within the state or not um there the big
big picture question um whether we
should do that what that means to the
free market and what class what whether
that consolidation results in Monopoly
and the determination of whether or not
a monopoly that's a pretty big question
right now that but it is definitely a
question but again we go back to we have
a limit currently in statute on the
number of gaming operations and the
number of historic for well not the
number of gaming operations but the
number of historic horse racing
operations we have unlimited gaming
operations are available right now per
statute but gaming uh horse historic
horse racing licenses are limited to 15
um the current lenses and if we pass 472
that number goes up to about 20 so I
think there's five in in the in the
pipeline that POS that would be eligible
again doesn't mean they're going to get
them it just means that they're El they
would be classified as eligible for the
next seven years to be able to apply so
we know that there's a limit of on HHR
only we have a li of 20 possible
licenses assuming 472 passes for the
next seven years on the games of chance
side there's no restriction right so
just making sure we're all clear and
understand how what that what it looks
like as a
picture represent just just a follow up
on on a if a business buys a business
that has a license does that new
business have to get preapproved or yes
okay yeah they they would go through the
same vetting process unless it was an
already already approved business oh
right say one wants to make buy a second
one then they've already gone through
the process absent corporate changes if
they're still the same people the same
business doing the same things they
would be we would still approve them but
the process would be a lot easier I see
thank you thank you Mr chairman so this
business has already been sold and the
new new owners are operating it no no
there's been no change in the status of
the conquer facility so the bus business
has been sold but transferred yet nope
it hasn't not it's still in the status
it was in 6 months
ago for the most part okay so the the
sale of the business contingent about
them obtaining a license so no
connection they have the right to apply
for one but correct so they if if if if
and I'll say it's hypothetical and my
lawyer's next to me so I I'll speak
let's be careful representative um if a
business wants to purchase this they
could they would come to us they would
submit an application and then we would
review the application for their
suitability where that's where it says
okay and the application is for the
license and that moves the business
forward or not correct the application
is for the entire is for the business
itself and what form they want to take
that is an open question but certainly
the
they would apply to us and it's
hypothetical now because I don't know if
if or when somebody would apply what
they would say or do or how they would
submit it because it's it's a
hypothetical thank
you yeah follow
up again so in the case of conquer
there's been no change the owner still
is the owner and as far as anybody knows
there's been no sale so nothing is
happening there right now but my the one
point I want to make is that if because
Charlie brought it up was if the makeup
of a corporation changes they that
change has to be go through the similar
process with lottery for Who's involved
and they have to go through their
background checks and everything else it
just understand that even in the makeup
of an existing operation if it changes
hands or changes percentage ownership in
the LLC that change has to go through
Charlie as well for approval process
that correct Charlie correct yep thank
you John I have your name next to this I
don't know if there's anything else
Dr 40 Chief compliance officer for the
new Hamp Lottery um I know you had put
put me on the agenda I think everything
that's been said is 100% accurate as
Senator Lang just said anytime there's a
change of ownership of 10 at 10% or more
we do a review of that um so if it's
even a minor transfer of a minority
ownership we would still vet that um vet
that transfer so um in terms of um
conquer as stated there's there's been
no change at this point in time um and
yep so everything else that you've
discussed is absolutely accurate in
terms of
transfers okay
so again the license is with the the the
current whoever the owners are now like
just do it one more time for me so if we
have a a partial change in
ownership how does that work yeah sure
so let's say you were a license holder
you had a business and you wanted to
sell a 20% stake in that business um you
would have to um submit that information
to the Lottery Commission to let them
know who the new 20% owner was um and
then we would do a suitability review on
the new 20% owner a suitability review
We review um the criminal background we
uh the gaming background the financial
background of the uh new company any uh
key employees for example uh if it's a
corporation we look at the officers we
look at board members um and so we would
do a review of that um we would come up
with a uh a factual report uh and a
recommendation which would go over to
the Attorney General's office the
Attorney General then does their own
independent review um and we confer and
either decide whether that new group
would be suitable or not that is that
approval is necessary before that
transfer can go into effect so what I'm
hearing is that very much like a new guy
coming in exactly like a new guy coming
in so basically vetted the same way as
what I'm hearing here it is so any
really any material
transfer essentially triggers uh a new
review as if it were a new application
um and I will say we we set the
automatic Threshold at 10% but for
example we need to be we need to told of
every transfer um and so for example if
we if we got a transfer 3% to Sam
bankman freed or something like that we
have authority to go look into any
transfer at any level um so the 10% is
just a default rule but we can certainly
look beyond that if there are concerns
or points of interest on those
transfers thank you Mr chairman why
wouldn't you look into any percentage at
all oh somebody come no coming in like
even
1% we could um so for example often
times some of these companies have
passive investment groups uh behind them
um and so there might be changes in
passive investors who have nothing to do
with the actual operation so we might do
a a if uh if there is a uh 3 to 5%
change in a passive ownership group um
we would certainly review it to make
sure that we understood what was going
on but we might not it might not trigger
a full suitability review because that
group doesn't have any um any sway in
sort of the uh the overall funding of
the operation uh the day-to-day
operation of gaming um so it's not uh it
wouldn't necessarily be relevant um so
again 10% is just a a a rule um but if
we we look at everything that changes
and if even if it was a 2% change that
we thought was relevant to the operation
or we had concerns about the people
coming in we would look at that but
there are instances especially with
passive investment groups where it
doesn't make sense to uh to to use the
time and the resources uh to chase down
that small of a percentage change in
some in a company that doesn't really
have any um active involvement in the in
the
business and and just so the the
committee knows uh the Attorney
General's office can initiate a
suitability investigation at any time
and so what what happens at Lottery um
is the pretty standard normal process of
how things transferred or how new people
come in but if the Attorney General
deems it appropriate then uh our office
can go ahead and initiate an
investigation so as sponte uh the other
thing I I i' perhaps maybe ask U Mr coni
to talk a little bit about is is uh how
transfers work publicly traded
companies sure so um there are there are
often changes in publicly traed
companies in terms of the stock moves uh
quite often um and so we review the
filings that come across the SEC uh the
the 10K filings that um occur um but
again I think what uh maybe Mr Del Forno
is going going to is public TR companies
literally change ownership every day so
um those it wouldn't be feasible to do a
review on on those uh but those are
obviously fractional changes on a on a
ongoing basis if there are management
changes in a publicly trigger company
that's when we would jump in and take a
look at new management new CEO new board
members um new uh key executive officers
um but to Mr Del far's point which it
would be is a very good one one I should
have latched on earlier um several of
our uh licens are publicly companies and
the the they change ownership as we
speak um so it wouldn't obviously be
feasible to to identify all of those
changes so just focus on that a second
so how many publicly traded companies I
mean I mean I don't know if Delaware
North is or if uh Churchill Down is is
you know we have some big players in
now uh who who of them are Churchill
Downs is a publicly traded company
and actually
now I believe that might
be that might be the only one who's
currently um who's currently uh licensed
um we obviously deal with DraftKings
who's also a public ler company right
and um we have some other companies
who've um expressed interest who are
publicly traded but presently Churchill
Down's the only one who has a games en
traded any other question questions for
John see thank you very much
so all right
um yeah we we we as a group are going to
have to come to terms with I think some
of the issues that were brought up a few
minutes ago about the limits on the
licenses how many anyone organization I
want I want to bring this up again in a
few minutes when we start talking
because I did a pretty good look I do
spend a lot of time looking at the
ranges of the sizes of these
organizations from from what the
Charities get perspective but this
really really is brings out loud that we
got a wide range of of owners here we
got a wide range of size of facilities
that we're talking about and that and uh
and that I think like was someone
mentioned that maybe it's not just the
uh number of licenses I think it's the
amount of dollars that are behind each
one of those licenses in terms of the
the size of the facilities that we're
talking about because some of them are
pretty tiny actually so um so anyway we
we'll we'll that's definitely on the
list of things to for us to
resolve uh one of the other issues that
was on the list and has been on is
breakage what we want to resolve I keep
on bringing this one
up uh uh I think we're getting close I
think we know that
the uh I guess there's two vendors that
Pro provide historic racing machines
that are not there's four total
Charlie's going away I need take a
phone uh okay can you help me I can
address any of those questions yeah okay
uh that uh two two are are paying into
the bucket for the breakage and the
other two just don't have it in their
software
I think to summarize I think we as a as
a committee have agreed the very least
that we should have the the ones that
aren't contribute something to the pot
of uh chable of U um to uh problem
gaming and to give you an idea when you
24 and you go on the second
page uh br breakage for problem gaming
for February 24 was
15,964
20,800 so so we're right now we're we're
getting contributions of about 200,000
annually uh from the two vendors now
it's my understanding that the other two
vendors probably even bigger and that uh
what I was I is Charlie I know if we can
have done by today is to come up with a
number first we have as a committee we
have to agree how we want to handle us
but I think we're getting
closer
okay yep okay Charlie has an emergency
has to deal with So Sorry Charlie see
you um John is Gonna Fill In firm what
so I guess we I I had asked Charlie can
we come up with a
number that would be
fair uh that we should charge the other
vendors an annual fee that may be
variable depending on how many machines
year I if you had this conversation with
him we did have this conversation so um
I I did look at this representative Ramy
um and we as you said uh you had the
numbers for February uh very similar
numbers for March uh we had about
$6,500 in
breakage um for March so it continues on
that trend of around 16,000 uh a month
um about 55% of the overall machines uh
create breakage in the state um 45 do
not and just to clarify this a little
bit there are four tote machines in
operation
um three of them do contribute breakage
it's only one that does not that would
be um from uh answorth um does not um uh
does not create uh breakage off of their
tote machine again only one only one
correct but they are orig then I was
talking Char on the phone you said it's
was two no it's it's one uh they are one
of the larger uh there's really two
large tote companies and two very small
tote companies the two very tote small
tote companies do contribute breakage um
but they are at this point one of the
totes is only uh available in one room
is only 50 um terminals U operating off
of them so um it's a very very very
small percentage of the overall uh
Market um so if you wanted to get a
sense of the overall um sort of the
overall impact of not creating that that
that um the absence of that a breakage
from that one operator um it's it would
essentially we would think about double
the the the breakage if they were
operating on the same with the same math
models that the others did um because
again they represent about 45% of the
market um so if we're expecting you know
again to be on that trend of about
$200,000 that would certainly be a a
give or take again within a tolerance of
5 to 10% that would be what we would
expect from break age if they were
running the same math model so I feel
more comfortable if we could take that
number the well this February number 15
whatever I would take a larger sample
than this one month but but then
calculate that against the number of
machines or number or some some Metric
probably maybe
breakage by the machines that
are are creating this
uh uh you know for the problem Gaming
revenue U so that we could say okay
that's comparable and then then that'll
be a fee for the first year and then a
fee for the second year would have to be
adjusted based on that any any change in
that mix
of of uh of use if you
will sure sorry yes I can make a
recommendation as I've been looking at
this I think probably the easiest metric
that'll deal with growth growth is what
current breakage looks like as a
percentage of handle right and then use
that as a metric going forward and then
but I also don't want to force the
people that are currently praying
breakage to change their software to
have to now comply with the new law so I
think it's an either or it's either
should be a percentage of gross handle
as one or whatever the current law is
and and the operator can pick either one
to work from so that it's not
problematic We Don't Force One company
to either start creating a breakage
model the other one to have to abandon
their breakage model and have to
reprogram theirs so I think it should be
an either or and a percentage of handle
gross handle probably seems you can
probably look back historically and say
based on the handle what percentage are
we collecting in breakage and then use
that going forward that'll deal with
growth of the market as well we we can
absolutely do that we have all that data
Senator um and so we can basically um
any way that you want to chop up the
data we can do that if you want to do
breakage as a percentage of of um handle
we certainly can provide the historic uh
information on that I could just say
just to to to um put a finer point on it
from the lottery commission's
perspective we really would not like to
force uh a software change uh because
that would require essentially going in
and um redoing the software on about a
thousand terminals uh around the state
and every time there's a software change
we have to allocate resources um both in
our office and in the field to make make
sure that that change is done
appropriately and has been tested and um
so it would be a massive undertaking uh
to uh force that software change I don't
think I don't think that's the direction
we want to go in either uh we just want
to make it fair that the others are are
contributing something to to uh to
problem gaming you know breakage some
kind of an estimate of breakage if you
will uh proportional to the machines
that are calculating the
breakage as best we can absolutely we
can I think we can that's something you
can do between now and next meeting give
us a give us a sense well put me as the
so we got a problem a little problem we
want to fix it what what do we want to
do and I I think and we don't want to we
want to force the vendors to come up
with software changes that doesn't make
any sense and I I I think I agree with
Tim is is that it's either it's in
either War leave it up to the vendors
which way they want to do it if you if
they already have they already have the
software they could continue to do that
if they don't then we're going to we're
going to come up with a number we're
going to say every year you're going to
pay X and that's but proportional to
growth in certain things whatever the
metric is as we were talking about so uh
we we I don't think is it safe to say
that none of us want to force the sof
the vendors to to create software I
don't see anybody saying
yes but I'm not seeing anybody saying
that we shouldn't charge the others to
come up with an equivalent number
because we really are not charging them
to even work here so this is going to be
kind of their dues if you would Mr chair
if I could add we have talked to xacta
which is the largest um tow company that
does create breakage um they can also
from what they've represented I can I
can reach out to them and double check
again that they can sort of turn that
off in favor of a a straight fee model
you know a pay payment of a of an RG fee
on the front end um and either return
that breakage into the pool where it
could be won by the players that that is
not a software change for them that's
just a quick configuration so um again I
haven't spoken to the two smaller
vendors and what that might entail if we
decide to uh to to let everybody move
towards a just a a fee for uh fee to to
to participate in the market that would
go towards RG funding um I know that
xacta has the ability to do that with
very minimal um with a very minimal
impact okay so also my understanding is
that if that happened in all four
that'll be a there'd been writing checks
out of their out of whatever
resources um and that would that would
mean it'd be more an a poot for
Charities it it it would it would return
that that money into uh the pool which
would uh increase uh increase prices
would probably increase play um so it
could it could have a a positive impact
on eventually on state revenue and then
charity Revenue as well just want to
make sure we all understand that
repres yeah I think we're you you asked
for reactions to this it sounds good to
me but I'd like to see it and think yeah
and um the other point is that uh if it
turns out let's say it's
$200,000 um that's not to say that's the
right number for problem gaming fund
that's uh what it comes to from like
these formulas and
practices uh but that's all it is and we
it may have landed in the right range or
or not let's look at that separately
sounding like it's going to double the
200 and effect you said 55% something so
let's call it 400,000 we'll find out a
number it would be roughly that it's
it's not as simple as it it won't
necessarily scale exactly one to one but
it should be roughly in that
neighborhood between 350 and 400 ,000
would be my guess the problem gaming is
a whole another issue on still on the
table that we have to address because
right now it's it needs work I
mean right now basically there's money
going out but it's not being
used it's from our prior meetings so
that that'll be back on the agenda
pretty soon uh but at least we we have a
source of revenues uh consistent source
of revenues yes we do have a source of
Revenue I would just uh add um that the
one of the limiting factors though is
what what is budgeted right now so I
believe what's budgeted for this year is
250,000 so obviously the breakage is
shouldn't meet that number this year um
but if breakage exceeded the number uh
that was budgeted really right now with
the U the commission that's in place
right now they are limited at
$250,000 without taking further action
so there is also that for the
consideration um of the Commission in
terms of recommendations coming out of
here is whether you know obviously
they'll be addressing the source but
also maybe addressing the the um the
budget side of that as well to allow
those sources those funds to flow
through to RG Services okay quick yeah
so John take homework assignment so um
if we could get take a look at the two
existing players and what percentage of
handle they they're paying um
extrapolate that out out for the for the
other players that aren't currently
paying and then kind of give us a fiscal
note if you will of what a bill like if
we if we were to establish at this
percentage of gross handle the people
that aren't paying would pay this much
people that are paying would continue to
pay this much and this is what the
revenue would look like at the end so we
kind of Canon have a big picture of what
this looks
you any other questions or comments on
this one okay
let's move on to agenda item seven range
of annual charity
revenues
now
so we all got this document sent to us
and I've been inform everybody maybe it
was just me but this is It's a detail of
listing by facility of all the Charities
they sponsor or that sponsored
them uh in the number of
days and what the allocations
were of uh to to the charity before rent
then then the HHR allocation then broken
out then it this gets broken out by HHR
and then GOC and then the
rent um Etc so and there's one sheet or
a couple of sheets depending on how big
the facility is uh listing all of
these so what I
I are you looking at um to yeah that's
that this is for the
this is for fiscal year uh calendar year
it's for calendar year
23 we just got this sent from since the
last
meeting but anyway I took that to
summarize it and it's before you I have
the sheet looks like
this looks
like
um and it's just summarizing
the amount of money that it's going to
the
Charities before rent okay before rent
and I'm assuming that with rent going
away that these will more reflect the
numbers of what these Charities are
going to
get and then well there's 14 locations
one two three 14
locations and you and I I I put them
based on the cont amount that's going to
Charities from each one of those facili
ities and you can see the Brooks on the
top at $8
million Gate City is comes in second
about 5.2 million bante too is at 4.5
million chases is about 4 million over
Poker Room about 2.2 then it goes all
the way
down to Northwood
casino at
111,000 and you go up one from that Ace
and8 casino is at 13
3,000 and then one from that is is
conquer Casino while it was still open
the 338,000 so this is the amount that
went
to the
Charities now interestingly enough you'd
say well Aces must not
have
uh historic racing but they
do of and and
it's what actually goes to the charity
average day I what I did is because that
this report gave the number of calendar
days that that U that each charity had
most have 10 a matter of fact that the
two far the three columns on the
left says how many 10 days slots did
each each like the brook had 70
Charities that had 10day blocks and
there were six others that had something
less than that equated to six that
equated to six days okay so so a total
of 76 Charities that they were involved
in Gate City had 71
Charities that functioned for 10
days and there were four others that
amounted to five
days
so um excuse
me yeah
so basically there were
93.6% of the Charities had 10day blocks
across all of the facilities and 6.4% is
something less than five day 10 days
they may have had one they may have had
five in some cases they get at nine but
it's not 10 so I just wanted to just
wanted to point that out
but
so you can
see
that depending on where you are you're
involved the average the average 10 days
at the brook average is
$110,000 for tells 10 days but
interestingly enough Chase's poker room
which doesn't have does not have
historic racing machines also you can
$110,000 so but they only sponsored 39
Charities total okay some again n nine
of them will had less
than 10day
blocks and they then again they don't
have historic racing so they only the
maximum number days they can be open is
365 so uh with one
sponsor and then but then again if you
if you you look down you go wow
some of these places are pretty
small I mean uh and the Charities with
10 days would walk away with you
know like like four of them or under
$10,000 for that
effort um and but you could see you
could see the numbers yourself it it's
there are top tier if you will that are
larger and then there's those that are
smaller
page and it is manually I did it every
$5,000 increments just to give you a
sense of the distribution of those
averages so Lakes Region for instance
the first one
there three of those
Charities were somewhere between receive
somewhere between Z and $5,000
16 received between 5,000 and $51 and
$110,000 13 between $10,000 and $1
15,000 or 13 of
them then 15 five six were between
15,000 100 so there
distribution one one want but between
20,000 and
25,000 so again there a lot of small
ones but then you get to the the bigger
ones then you get to Great Gate City and
it's quite a range of what the Charities
walked away with three were 45,000 to
50,000 16 what's the highest 50,000 to
55,000 but then there were there were
that night they must have had good dates
because there was one that walked away
with between 15,000 and 120 you can
identify them if you go to the
detail uh was one that was 135 to
140,000 one
160,000
165,000 so it's just not the average
that I talked about in the first sheet
how that distributes
out now we could say well maybe they had
good dates some of them or it could be
it could be a holiday weekend it could
be a
whatever or could be that they did a
good job as a charity getting people to
come to the facility that they and
there's nothing wrong with this there's
nothing wrong with the
Charity saying to its membership hey we
got a charity night that's the way it
used to be we have a charity night make
sure you come and you know it could be
some of that here I don't know I have no
idea then you have a place like
uh CPR that's Chase's Chase's poker
room which does not have
historic racing who does quite well I
these Charities most of the Charities
are over
$100,000 okay that they that they that
they're
receiving um and then we have place like
the Brooke which is the TB on the top
there the
brook you know I looked at that one
number that 45 to
500,000 interestingly enough and that
one night or one
day they they did not have games of
chance going because it was Zero revenue
for the games of
chance uh but they had their historic
racing go for whatever reason maybe it's
because they only had one charity I
don't know but you can double check my
math when
you valer
but but at the brook again they're
pretty consistent you know most of them
they approached
100,000 and two two two
Charities were orang 140 to
145,000 and then one which is the top
gain of any of the facilities 180 to
185,000 so I I think data is important
to look at just to get a sense
of the distribution
here and and then if you look at the far
right column
um well the totals there doesn't matter
what facility what what how many how
many
Charities walked away with zero to 5,000
32 how many walked away 5,000 to
10,077 10,000 to
15, 148 that was the biggest number so
the key thing is that when you look at
the distribution
between zero and
25,000 that
represents 49.7% of the Charities let's
call half the
Charities that's their take okay
something less than 25,000 for 10 days
these are all 10 days these are 10day
numbers okay for 10
days you know but then you then then you
can see the distribution it goes up to
uh you know when you hit 50,000 between
Z and 50,000 that's well that's another
19.2% so that's
68% only only
125,000 as as a
charity uh and then if you if you look
between 100,000
8.3% of Charities make that amount so
um the reason I'm I'm talking about this
is because I was challenging myself in
one of the meeting saying you it's there
there going to be a day that in which
we're going to have to
limit the upper end of the of what a
charity can receive or
not uh just thinking that as the
facilities grow
is this something that we're going to
have to quite a
limit
um right now it doesn't look that way
because it seems to be self-limiting but
I think there's going to be a day when
we're gonna I think I think we're still
gonna have to answer that
question um and then the mechanism to do
that is is up up to grabs um but
um what I'm going to try to do is I
think we should try to understand why
some of these Charities did so well
compared to the other
ones um is was it something that they
were able to do to bring more people
into the facility or not yep I actually
want to ask Norm his take on this
considering he's a charity and the idea
whe limiting the charity component model
and how much revenue they can make what
are your general thoughts on as a
charity who's representing Charities
that are receiving
room oh
I limiting here you're basically going
over and you're picking the winners and
losers all of a sudden um that if I
remember right here looking at some of
the information that we have got that we
have gotten over the the course of the
several months one thing that stuck out
to me here was I think it was at the
brook not sure facility but it was
sponsored again it was a large day if
you want okay or week women's uh women's
business
organization more than likely they went
over and they just pestered their
members get out there spend your money
you know I mean because that's uh and I
think that that's one of the items where
the dollars are really coming in
um I think you've got to give it a lot
longer period of time before all of a
sudden just that's you know going over
and all right we you know start limiting
all right because
the the cause has certainly you know
again an effect on bringing people in if
they if they uh send it out get an email
Facebook Facebook the uh other one is is
that uh some of those Charities if you
want have far again a a u they have an
extensive
Service uh performance or service area
if you want that they're doing if it's
the cancel fund future in sight I'm
looking at uh
versus
a a local uh if you want organization
I'll you liance Club you know your
basically have a service area that that
encompasses several
towns uh some of the dollars go to the
to the state but it's a it's far
different again if you want your
operating budget from from a charity
Point than if you're looking at a
Statewide uh you know cancer
organization that they're servicing the
the entire state so that they they go
over and and use every dollar usually
again that they that they can uh any
dollars not used again are are put aside
in the uh endowment or you know for for
future service so the limitations I
think here you can possibly look at in
several years and I think when you
finally get a stabilization if you want
of our of our gaming uh industry okay
thank
you any other comments on
that um I want to back it up to the
disparaging rates from the Charities I
mean we're dealing with gambling so
you're betting on people losing when
Charities win so just
for you know that sake you never know
when the best week is going to be I've
seen the best week in August I've seen
it in October I can't predict it I think
all of the rooms are planning promotions
on a daily basis so we're trying to
bring people in and doing things at our
expense to get people to get the foot
traffic it's highly competitive there's
a lot of rooms like I don't think
there's a day I walk in where every
single machine's filled by any means so
you move the machines around you change
the games it's a
constant something that we assess but I
will say for last year for Gate City
we're going back to a Monday to Sunday
block it does keep people on a little
more of a Level Playing Field we did 10
days last year because we weren't fully
expanded so we started with seven and
then I added three for each additional
charity because frankly they didn't make
what they made the year prior so they
budgeted for more we weren't fully
expanded the machine machines didn't
take off right away they're new to the
state so we were still building that
marketing plan but just to shed a little
light on some of
those different numbers and kind of how
that happens just so as far as the
ceiling I'm very hesitant um on putting
a ceiling on the numbers just because I
sit on three nonprofit boards and
there's always more we want to do and
there's things you don't do that you
can't do that fall to the Wayside
because you don't have the funding so I
think most could easily use more of the
funding and when we select Charities on
my committee that selects Charities I
pitch some Charities they select them
when we select them we keep in mind like
what is your mission statement where
what is this going to do for the
community and we decide dates on that
the Charities that got like a few more
condensed dates were basically the last
week of the month just for
little explanation there but sorry to
back
up yeah my concern was that you know
first I thought it was it was an eye
open for me to see that that someone
walked away with 180,000
plus um which is great I mean I'm not
discouraging that I'm just saying
it's because my my idea was that we
don't want to hurt anybody who's been
making a certain amount you know all
along
you know let's say 120,000 every
year so that we would we have to draw
the line somewhere but geez seems like
there's some that are making 180
140,000 now I haven't checked to see if
that's consistent every year or that's
just an operation for that particular
charity uh but again it's just it's on
the list of things to talk about um
joh um yeah I was just saying the um
it's true that the Charities are limited
to 10 days per month yeah it can be less
than what's that year 10 days per year
yeah yes year oh so to me that's a
limiting factor right there I mean you
can only do so much in 10 days so um I I
don't know at this juncture I would be
against putting a cap on because the 10
days to me is a limiting
factor yeah so and I think I'm remember
as you or John brought it or Norm
brought it up but again you're almost
penalizing a charity that especially a
Statewide charity that pushes out to
their members everybody show up
everybody come and then everybody shows
up and comes and you don't get all the
money that was raised based on your
effort as a charity to come in do that
so again I kind of agree with John I
think our limiting factor is 10 days
you're never going to resolve the
disparity between Northwood casino and
the brook um and and in making Northwood
Casino somehow give more money to
charity um so I don't know how we would
pick stat as a legislature in a
statutory kind of thing so I like John I
think our limiting factors the 10 days
not the amount of money they make
because the effort matters um and so
either the effort of the casino to that
does advertising to get people in their
door or the effort of the charity to get
their members to bring their friends to
come in and support their cause um I
think we start putting caps on that
we're we're we're um penalizing effort
the lack of a better phrase so I'd be
I'd be resistant to do a a a cap I think
our cap is 10 days whether we want to
talk about bringing up down to seven so
we can get more charities in that's a
reasonable conversation I think um so
that we can service more Charities but I
don't know that we put a cop on a dollar
so in in uh from the front sheet what I
was talking from the total Charities
involved in uh 2023 was 800 even 800
Charities again most had 10 days 94% 95
almost well 94 let's call it
94% had had 10 days and I think it goes
back to that think G made the comment um
um they're going to sday weeks it's
easier scheduling wise right because it
makes a difference you have 10 days that
includes two weekends you're make a heck
a lot more money than if you have seven
days only one weekend right because of
when people show up to game right and so
by going to that s-day window they can
both service more charity and equalize
playing field a little bit with the
charity so I think that's a reasonable
kind of action but I think that's where
we should have our discussions around do
we want to stay at 10 or go down to
seven not do we want to cap how much
Gia just curious have you folks done any
kind of data analysis to figure out if
there's a correlation between specific
Charities their ability to bring people
in and some of the results that you know
we see here on the chart for Bri Gade
City or is this just random it's random
and I think it has very little impact
like I love when they promote it if
they're comfortable promoting it I never
want us to eliminate a cause because
it's against our Miss statement and I'm
not going to pressure them to promote it
like ever so I mean I it's nice if they
want to I support that you want to come
in I'll Reserve an area we'll promote it
you'll promote it I'll have my marketing
team make some material for
you but it's all about your comfort
level so that's something when I accept
the paperwork and we sign you know the
paperwork together and I mail it up we
have that discussion and I say if you're
interested I will connect you with my
marketing team if not that's okay
because I don't think it should be
mandatory by any means and you would
lose a lot of Charities I mean it's
great I want the promotion but I'm not
going to force you to do something that
doesn't work with your mission
statement right technically it's it's
voluntary uh marketing if you will by
these by Charities they're doing it
because they know if they get more
people in the building
they're but but frankly like if people
don't win they don't come so like you
might invite somebody that wins a
lot um when we did the $50 Max bet I had
C come do a bet and I joked with him he
stole from charity because he won like
one spin on roulette and he donated
twice as much back so it was funny but
uh regardless like if they don't win
they don't come back so you can invite
all the people you want it really
depends on is that person winning or are
they losing and that is what correlates
to what they get that's the net you
cannot predict that but it's a no no
traffic is good no foot traffic is good
off for facility to say you have to have
a function one of those days that you
you right that we we do not do that I
will not speak forever but absolutely
like at my establishment we do not even
suggest like you have to have a function
I say if you want to come down during
your week I'm happy to host and and
frankly
typically I show up with my and I get
them around and sit them down and
reserve a little area like it's not like
a money maker by any means it's more
like thank you for coming and partnering
and supporting
us what the statute say on that so it is
not permissible to require any type of
event or to to cross sell a service in
order to get game dates it's something
that has been brought to the commission
attention before um and I don't think
it's uh something that happens often in
fact it was addressed in the um uh in
the study uh that we just went out we
asked the Charities whether they were
pressured to have an event or to uh buy
any services and I don't have the
results in front of me right now but it
was a very very small percentage of
people who indicated that they um felt
any pressure to do an event or anything
um Associated at the facility but it is
not permitted at all and so if we get
any word of that we address it uh
immediately right but if the charity
decides to do something on their own
just to promote their dates that that
Mak sense and then and obviously the
facilities I mean there are facilities
that are
ritiz and alandre pointed it out I mean
we see these TV commercials too but but
that's legitimate I mean they can
promote their their business don't helps
out yeah want to go back to the
discussion about uh uh limits on
revenues and uh I
share the thought that uh if
there AR to be limits they should be a
consequence of the numbers of days that
are allocated and um there are a couple
of ways of doing that one is to reduce
the numbers of days and expand the
number of Charities
um uh that can benefit it during any
particular day um and um
then that's one way that it it could be
accomplished um or or another thought is
that uh maybe for those Charities uh
those uh venues that
um Produce High
revenues maybe that's where you have
have a an additional day additional
charity involved each day uh we can
think about that but I I think we should
think about
how there's no NE necessary correlation
in the system we now have between the
money that's generated and awarded to a
charity and the size of that charity or
the needs of that charity is just uh you
know you you get your days and you get
your money and now you've been running a
uh a little small
local uh charity for home homeless
people and you've got um five times the
money that you had before and now what
do you do with it well maybe it but it's
an ongoing flow of money so all of a
sudden you become a different kind of
entity than you were to start with you
know just now the randomness of this
current situation that we have it is and
I think I think folks I think the
Charities recognize that that they're
dealing with a smaller facility they're
not they're probably not going to make
that as much but it's still in the old
days $5,000 was a lot you know that they
were happy with with making something my
concern is
that that right now we're up to 800
Charities at least for last count of
year and I'm looking at if con if cono
is totally kaput that's 35 Charities
that lost their place
to and some of these other smaller ones
I I don't know I mean how do they do
they exist forever and ever is it is it
going to be competitive for them to keep
on uh functioning I don't know that's a
Marketplace thing really that's uh but
you got to remember
50% of the Charities only receive
$25,000 or less
50% and I'm not worried about the
Brooker I'm not worried
about some of these other larger
facilities they they're going to do just
fine matter of fact their numbers are
going to grow what's going to happen is
not necessarily the number of Charities
are going to grow it's going to be the
amount that each of the current
Charities are
get uh versus some of the smaller places
that
are more likely to run into financial
problems on their own and not not be
there next year and then we what we've
done is have a net less loss on the
number of Charities that are are gaining
here that that's where my somewhere in
there there's we have to try to come up
with something that that
will uh maybe not stop the growth in
what a charity gets but slow it down a
little bit so that we can let allow
other charities in now going in seven
days yeah that would do it that would
automatically do it it's going to hurt
some of the Charities though of that are
are getting 120,000 a year consistently
not only have seven days instead of the
10 days
so yeah it on one hand I almost feel
like it's a little bit premature to know
we would be limiting days or not because
we don't know what the complete
Marketplace looks like this Market is
still growing as we look at these
numbers year-over-year there's
significant gains that means um as
there's more significant gains and
licenses slowly increase there's still
plenty of Charities out there that want
to partake in this so it it's um I would
hesitate to make that determination
without kind of seeing where this
Marketplace is
going and I think we we're going to have
something to say about that too by the
end of this commission this to yeah what
what the ceiling should be it be the
number of machines or the number of
facilities or something there we we'll
get from the consultant what what's the
reasonable capacity of volume of
machines for a state our size to help us
guide us a little bit uh but you know no
one would have
envisioned if for real Casino bills if
you will real casinos I mean with the
maximum was maybe three or
four and we're going to have we're going
to have probably 19 once this is all
said and
done um but that may not stay some of
those guys may
merge right some of them may go out of
business you know I you know we don't
know I kind of agree with you John I I
think I think we have to put the we have
to kind of guess what the ceiling is
going to be here in terms of this well I
think one of these days we're going to
have to come to a decision how many how
many Charities are not being served yeah
at this point in time how many are not
being served right right now we know
that there's there's a group that are
being are being who's not being served
that that's number one and how how does
that constituency get served what what
kind of things can be done at at the
state level to make sure that that that
that happens sort of like leveling the
playing field we talk about that all all
the time
and I think as new items are introduced
we have historic horse racing now which
has been introduced big deal but what
else is going to be
introduced that's going to expand you
know the the ability to gamble which I
think is uh is critical as as we move as
we move forward here and and I think how
much is too much because I think you
pointed it out
the losers make
winners and and there there's a point
there's a point in time when the loser
the losers will become
problematic and that creates a series of
of social problems that that we have to
we have to deal with and as as this
grows I think that segment grows and
that's the problem gaming segment that
that's going to grow fa dramatically is
the number of entities grows all all
things that I think have to be have to
be looked at
this you know this this has been growing
dramatically in the past 10 years
growing
dramatically and the uh the concerns
associated with that grow at the same
time and all things that that you can't
do everything you can't legislate
everything but indeed
um think there's there's going to come a
point in time when we have to we're
going to have to do
something right it's you
know trying to be fair to the Charities
too here and that you know if the
charity used to getting $120,000 a
year um I I personally will hesitate to
pull the plug on them and say hey well
no it's only going to be $90,000 a year
uh because many of them now become the
depended on this money they're used to
this
money
um and I'm I'm saying somehow I don't
have the I don't have the answer
obviously but I have the thought though
that something needs to be looked at
yes
yeah um
G before you said that these these
amounts or and these dates that it's
pretty random how the Charities perform
for our location yes for your location
and I'm looking at your location
sometimes like if you go to Hampton
obviously the summer is going to be
better of course we are pretty all over
the map year round in terms of the uh of
the Charities that you service is there
any kind of correlation maybe
year-over-year to how much money they
take out or I should really say receive
so to to address the chair's point if
charity a is used to getting
$125,000 a year is it
$125,000 every year or does it look
something more like hey this year it
might be 75 and next year could be 150
and then some other year it could be
45,000 is it more distributed like that
or is it like a consistent
year-over-year
situation it it absolutely varies um for
us like over a 7-Day period like if
somebody's like what do I budget I'll
tell them budget 6 ,000 to be safe like
I don't want you to be riant in your
budget for year on this because it is a
Gamble and it does vary so it's a little
unpredictable last year we just weren't
done our expansion so people were
disappointed they helped get HHR pass
they came and testified in front of many
of you and then I felt bad because it's
like they're like well we got this
across and we made less money cuz they
did in the beginning till we fully
expanded
um and then something else I wanted to
mention was with the Charities like you
need Charities to operate that's a true
partnership so I want to keep in mind
when we talk about like I can go to
seven days because I've been we've been
operating I have a big waiting list it's
very easy for me to like put other
people in but in the beginning I was
begging people to come in partner and
they did not want to they weren't
familiar with gaming not everyone
qualifies New Hampshire is much much
more unique than like Delaware that we
heard where you have to meet a lot of
requirements so those checks and
balances are there which I support but
I'd be very hesitant with five potential
rooms that will need two a day to drop
to seven because it might put some
people in a little bit of a pickle if
they can't find partners and then are
they just picking anybody at that point
okay Valerie while you're sitting there
I'm gonna ask you a question
Valerie is there any seasonality to
somebody I mean ocean probably ocean may
have some seasonal ocean gaming may have
some
the microne except for those rooms that
are as Gia said on on Hampton Beach
because they attract more business in
the summer than they would in the winter
um I I also want to point out that some
of the increase in the revenue is due to
the $50 bet and the addition of HHR
which 5 years ago they weren't making
this much money they've it's increased
year-over-year as we've increased the
charitable gaming
overall yeah if I if I could just add to
that too so there's obviously there's
places where there's clear seasonality
um however I think the problem with
making fundamental judgments on this
data right now is like you're looking at
calendar year 23 the beginning of
calendar year 23 looked nothing like the
end of calendar year 23 um we're still
in a massive growth cycle between the
$50 bet uh which came into effect July 1
23 um G is referencing her facility
which is a good actually good template
for where many of the facilities are
right now which is they are growing out
their HHR machines um so what H got in
January of 23 at one facility would look
completely different than what they
would get in December of 23 so right now
we're in such a growth cycle with regard
to um obviously the the legal changes on
the games of chance side but also one
the build out of machines and then um
you know the operators are also refining
their techniques uh refining the game
choices understanding their um I think
understanding their player databases and
how to drive those players more
efficiently to the facility so um we
are it is a there there is a lot of
change in this data in 23 but I don't
think it's related necessarily to um
seasonality and it's probably
significantly more related to growth
right
now I count I count four rooms that
don't have historic racing
machines uh chases the river River
Casino
uh Parker which is know holding pattern
and
Northwood was there one other
a 31 Char 31 no but I saw I saw they I
when I looked at the revenues they had
historic racing Aces and eight does have
historic course racing they were
previous uh previously a um seasonal
room they would close down for the
winter so that's why they don't have the
all right I do think that we're trying
to build an airplane in the air right we
made so many changes and you know so I I
think it struggle when we start talking
about making significant changes I don't
think we've seen what normal is yet
because we keep changing the normal um
and so you guys keep at it too hey you
were you were
there so we I'll take some of the heat
but not all the heat um but you know are
legislatively we're making hu you know
how many gaming bills we've had in the
last four you know three terms right and
and and that have been proved in pass
and and the gaming operators are trying
to play catch up right now we got a new
law we got to adjust and change again
and that changes the norm and so I I'd
be you know I'd encourage like G did the
the gaming rooms to move the seven days
a week to to be able to get to more
charities in the Hampshire so more
Charities have opportunities I don't
know that we should legislate it yet
again because I think we're building a
plane in the air um and so um just
cautious about more changes until we can
figure out what this thing looks like
and I think Spectrum will help us with
that um because they're a little bit
better at prognostication looking out in
the future and seeing what's going on
based on current law and based on um
what's going on in the market overall
Nationwide um you know let's not forget
that we still don't know what this going
to look like because you know if we look
at our state revenues what's going on
with them right now right they're
they're a little behind and we don't
know whether charitable gaming is going
to follow that same path yet or not
either whether or not it's going to be a
continu its growth path or see a a
Slowdown in growth as we do with some of
the other revenues the business revenues
that are coming to the state so um I
just caution again too many dramatic all
right we got 10 minutes left um I got
two other agend agenda items uh one was
temporary regulations and I put Tim's
name Senator Lang's name here this is
just building off of Mark your comment
at the end of the last
meeting I want to make sure
that I would spend more time on this if
you feel we need to spend more time on
this it sounds like jel car does some
stuff that is temporary but it may not
be everything that we
need I want to make sure I'm addressing
are okay just wanted okay thank you
right and then on my 20 some plus list
of things hosting Community Revenue we
haven't really talked in this room about
it that much uh but it's a
legislature and is that in one of the
many bills that's out there 472 that's
it the one we just sent over to the
house it has a an option basically to
treat a municipality just like a charity
however again we the bill focuses on the
idea that this is always supposed to be
charitable gaming so the Charities have
the right of first refusal before any
town would get any days so well I agree
again but the idea again we focus that
the legislators made a conscious
decision to talk about charitable gaming
and that this is about the Charities and
so we put we put options in there for
towns so so if there are operators that
have room in their Cal in their schedule
they can insert however we don't mandate
that they insert that if they have a
waiting list the charity com first and
then the town comes in what was the bill
472 sp sp s SP 472 it's currently in
front of it passed the Senate and it's
currently in front of house and John
said they're GNA look at it in two weeks
we've already had the public hearing so
so we have a we put a component in there
to allow it but just understand we were
focusing on Charities not the
municipalities and we made it so
Charities have a right of first refusal
on all dates so by the time it we meet
again this probably would have been
voted out of your committee one way or
another right
okay s there's a good chance we'll have
a work session a week from tomorrow um
whether we execute that day or not that
I don't know obviously right now were
there any issues in the Senate with this
bill we added the municipal piece in um
from the origin we added the municipal
piece in uh based on comments and
everything else we added uh based on the
um not for Center for not for-profits
they asked us to make it South Chari
were the Frontline component we all
agreed in the Senate if I remember right
Lou you can correct me but I'm pretty
sure it was a 5- z vote coming out of
Senate Ways and Means everybody agreed
it was unanimous vote on the floor um
and a Voice vote on the floor so um
again I was no no consternation that
that I recall in in I'll put this on
next week next meeting's agenda it would
have been a probably votes by that point
um we will we can see if that's if if
the structure of that is what the
commission longterm wants to see for the
communities or not we would have to
answer you we would have at least have
discussed it whether we've exed or not
you know depends okay yeah but we will
have had a work session and and possibly
EXA it okay very
good all right let's talk about the next
meeting uh I'm going to recommend May
weeks well well we'll try to do it here
um I'm going to try to have the Spectrum
whoever are the consultant is assigned
to us in this meeting whether he come
here physically it's physically he'll be
in this room if it's not we'll have to
do it over at
Lottery uh so we just be flexible on
that and I could talk to you about
issues getting over there to
lottery so is everybody can everybody
make that date
six 10 o'cl
yep
okay I check and see
if yeah let's get
him yeah you won't be able to
make okay and I may
be
minute well why don't we stick with the
May 6 we better stay with the
may6 we're all set okay we are Jour